If your labor is progressing, we will then take you in to the Baby Place,...
...where we have 14 private labor and delivery suites.
We have many amenities to help you and your family stay comfortable.
We have jetted tubs to help with the comfort of labor.
We have birth balls, telephones, free Wi-Fi throughout the hospital.
Our bed converts into various positions for labor and birth.
We have a sofa table that also converts into a bed for partners or support persons...
...and we can provide pillows, blankets and sheets.
We have TVs with movies, Pandora, MyChart, GetWellNetwork and more.
Right after birth,...
...we encourage you to have uninterrupted time with your newborn called Baby's First Hour.
For caesarian birth, we have three operating suites, as well as for private pre and post-op rooms.
We'll prepare for the birth of your baby.
We understand that birth doesn't always go as planned.
We have a neonatal intensive care unit that includes 30 state-of-the-art private rooms...
...and our babies have some of the best outcomes in the state.